hallo stefan
aha
du musst mir helfen
nämlich nicht
erinnere mich nicht
mir fällt dein name nicht ein
ich bin tanja
ich habe dich auch was
nicht erkannt
ich bin tanja
ich habe dich auch was nicht erkannt
tanja gehen
wir haben uns sehr lange nicht mehr
gesehen
stimmt das letzte mal als wir uns
gesehen haben war an unsere diplomfeier
wie lange ist das her
sicher schon 20 jahre
du hast dich gar nicht verändert
hast dich gar nicht verändert
aha danke aber das stimmt nicht
ich habe ein paar kilo zugenommen und
ein paar graue haare und falten bekommen
nein
stimmt nicht
das stimmt nicht
du siehst sehr gut auskommen schon
erzählt wie geht es dir
was hast du in den letzten 20 jahren
gemacht
also nach dem gymnasium habe ich an der
universität studiert
als
nach dem gymnasium habe ich an der
universität studiert
ich habe ein
die macht
ich habe ein in
studium gemacht
und du hast du studiert
ja ich habe tiermedizin studiert
zuerst habe ich eine weltreise gemacht
wow wie lange warst du reisen
ein jahr
wohin bist du gereist
in viele länder eben eine weltreise als
rucksacktourist
zuerst bin ich nach thailand geflogen
aus habe ich südostasien bereist
später bin ich nach australien und
neuseeland
und am schluss durch die usa gereist
später bin ich nach australien und
neuseeland
und am schluss durch die usa gereist
ich habe viel erlebt und tolle
erfahrungen gemacht
heute
die ich aus tierarzt
heute arbeite ich als tierarzt
was bist du mit deinem informatikstudium
geworden als was arbeitest du heute
ich arbeite für eine große it firma
ich leite an team das an einer
revolutionären methode arbeitet
elektrizität zu produzieren
ich leite an team das an einer
revolutionären methode arbeitet
elektrizität zu produzieren
das tönt interessant
und privat wie ist es dir privat
ergangen
und privat
wie ist es dir privat ergangen
ich habe einen freund wir haben
nicht geheiratet und wollten auch keine
kinder
ich habe einen freund wir haben
nicht geheiratet und wollten auch keine
kinder
es ist gut so wie es ist
und du hast du geheiratet
ja ich bin verheiratet und habe zwei
kinder
ich habe einen sohn der neun jahre alt
ist und eine tochter die sechs jahre alt
ist
ich habe einen sohn der neun jahre alt
ist und eine tochter die sechs jahre alt
ist
wir leben in einem dorf auf dem land
wir leben in
im dorf auf dem land
letztes jahr haben wir ein haus mit
einem großen garten gekauft
dort habe ich auch meine tierarztpraxis
und du wohnst du
ich lebe im ausland
in london habe ich mit meinem freund
eine kleine wohnung gemietet
in london habe ich
einem freund eine kleine wohnung
gemietet
er ist geschäftsmann und wie ich oft für
projekte unterwegs
die hälfte des jahres leben wir im hotel
aus dem koffer
das tönt spannend
das stimmt
aber langsam wünsche ich mir schon einen
festen wohnort
ich bin ja schließlich nicht mehr die
jüngste
aber langsam wünsche ich mir schon einen
festen wohnort
ich bin ja schließlich nicht mehr die
jüngste
wem sagst du das
hast du zeit für hobbys
ich gehe manchmal ins fitnesscenter
wenn ich zeit habe koch ich gerne
und du was sind
deine hobbys
und du was sind deine hobbys
bei den garten arbeiten kann ich mich
gut entspannen
ich lese auch gerne mal ein buch oder
schauen einen film
schauer einen film
ein bis zweimal pro woche
gehe ich rad fahren
ein bis zweimal pro woche gehe ich rad
fahren
am wochenende gehen wir oft wandern
hast du noch kontakt mit leuten von
unserer klasse
ja mit martin
er war an der gleichen universität wie
ich
martin was hat er studiert
martin hat er studiert
er hat recht studiert heute ist er
anwalt
er hat recht studiert heute ist der
das hätte ich nie gedacht
was das hätte ich nie gedacht
in unserer klasse hat er immer witze
gemacht und nie gelernt
irgendwie hatte aber den abschlusstest
bestanden und das diplom bekommen
in unserer klasse hat er immer witze
gemacht und nie gelernt
irgendwie hatte aber den abschlusstest
bestanden und das diplom bekommen
support hallo german school subscribe to
the channel wright in dokumente videos
möchtest du gratis online deutsch lernen
mehr als 200 video lektionen abonniere
unseren kanal möchtest du gratis online
deutsch lernen mehr als 200 video
lektionen abonniere unseren kanal